right Carol I must say this struck us as
we woke up this morning and at first
blush seems like a service strange
marriage between call of duty and candy
crush which are two quite different
games yeah brutality meets sweets is a
bit of a bizarre mixture but
interestingly it's relevant for where I
am right now because King is actually
based here headquartered in Ireland
making the most of the rather appetizing
corporate tax rate that they have in
Ireland but you're right this is a six
billion close to six billion dollar bet
on mobile call a duty maker World of
Warcraft has suddenly started to get the
taste for mobile gaming they've had half
stone is a digital card game at some
particularly well now they want to
embrace the franchise that is candy
crush and chronic house saga but what's
interesting it is well this maker King
digital has actually made more than 200
games I don't know about you but I can
only think of two those two candy crush
games they're going to have to start
being more than a one-trick pony they're
going to live up to six billion dollars
worth of value and I think that's what's
interesting today is a 16-percent
premium over wherever we're keen digital
was training for Easter day but compared
to its IPO price back last year this is
twenty percent under that people were
worrying about the future of this
company Davis what's the value
proposition for activism do they just
want to get into the smartphone game
I think that's exactly right everyone
here when you go to any tech event I
mean this is the biggest startup event
in the world Stephanie more than 40,000
people gathered here at the moment and
all of us as consumers now do what are
computing for our mobile now you'll
seeing the likes of Google get into the
enterprise space because probably going
to move enterprise onto mobile as well
it's all about being just a touch away
from your smartphone and I think this is
a big bet on mobile gaming analed
smartphone particularly when everyone
when they're commuting is still playing
candy crush that's the big that's a big
competitor to two people who want to own
your mobile space to the news even